this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where dad is dumb cash
is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice chris
hogan ramsey personality multiple number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
as we take your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
starting off this hour is going to be
anchorage alaska cindy is with us hi
cindy welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi chris thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so i had a question i'm currently in
baby step 3b
and i've been in alaska for on and off
for about nine years
working as a nurse um and i figured it's
time to
start looking to purchase either a condo
or a home
and i wanted to get your opinion um so
i'm currently i have where i could buy
a smaller one-bedroom condo but
kind of looking at the real estate
market it seems like those
condos have a longer i'm a resale like
you're on the market longer
so my question is is it better to go
ahead and purchase
like a smaller condo outright
or kind of wait a little bit longer and
either put a higher down payment on a
larger condo or a house or
obviously by 100 down but if that wasn't
the
ability so i just want to get your
opinion on that yeah cool so you're
you're
out of debt and you have your emergency
fund now you're saving your down payment
right
correct yes and i have enough that i
could buy like a small
like a one bedroom condo is like 105 to
115.
but um the resale on that is your income
yeah um anywhere depending on if i work
um
one or two jobs anywhere from 75 to 90
okay a year okay and so how long will it
take you to save up to buy
a little bit better than the one
bedrooms that don't set resale well
um i'm guessing probably about another
year
like to put 100 down but i could put
obviously that larger so you have a
hundred now
yes correct wow okay and how much longer
do you see yourself in alaska's
cindy well and that's kind of i have a
little gypsy soul so i've kind of been
i've got one foot in and one foot out
okay i i heard the southern come out
right there
in that gypsy soul thank you originally
we might be related that's
us you're from the motherland kentucky
that's good um
do you see yourself there another three
to five years or less
one half of me that's the and that's
where the caveat comes in one half of me
says yes because i didn't think i would
see myself here this long
okay i don't but at the same time don't
buy a one bedroom
yeah you told me three times uh that
they sell slow and they don't appreciate
well and so it's just not a good
investment i mean you already knew that
you didn't need me to say it you were
telling yourself that so the two
options are you wait and save unpay cash
for
a little bit better property that you
could resell if you get ready to move
and you're not stuck in it and that also
means it's going to go up in value
because time on the market is also
correlated with appreciation most of the
time
meaning if something sells really fast
it's hot it usually is going up in value
and so that's the you know those two
things the days on the market are
correlated with appreciation rate in
your mls statistics typically
so i i you know i'm okay if you buy
today
and put half down and pay the other half
off in three years
gotcha okay or yeah or if you want to
wait and pay a hundred percent
and you wait a year and a half or
whatever and you want to pay put 100
down either one's fine but i would not
buy the
soft market one bedroom now dave explain
the phrase
and this thing is said oftentimes in
real estate you make your money on the
buy
what does that mean well you you have to
buy something if you're gonna get a deal
add a deal
right and don't buy something that's got
a bad situation like those one bedrooms
in that market
aren't selling okay so that's you you
you know you made a poor decision at the
buy
it's not necessarily the money that you
made but that's going to cost you money
on the sale on the back end right and
like the first house
uh i ever bought was up on a hill
uh and it wasn't up on a good hill it
was like stuck in the side
of a bluff and nasty
and ugly i mean this house was ugly ugly
with a u
and i got a great deal on it but you
know what when i got ready to sell it it
was still
ugly and so i gave somebody a great deal
how long did it take for this thing to
move it took forever you know and so uh
that that's the problem you get into is
that
you know if the reason you got a good
deal is still there
when you get ready to sell you're gonna
give somebody a good deal
you know whether it's floor plan whether
it's the elevation from the street
whether it's the
fact that there's a flood of the one
bedrooms and they built too many of them
and a lot of the people
buying those necessarily aren't they're
not putting down routes
they're more transitory whatever yeah
whatever the reason is that you got a
deal going
in is the same reason you're going to
give a deal going out
unless you can change that and i mean if
the reason you got a deal was it was a
foreclosure
it needed carpet paint and a roof curb
appeal and the curb appeal is fine but
you just need to cut down all the big
bushes and put down some new landscaping
you had
25 year old you know plants out front
that look like crap that kind of thing
and you go in and do a makeover on the
house now that you've changed the
equation there
that one makes sense but cindy i would
tell you this
reach out get an endorsed local provider
somebody that can give you that
objective third party opinion and guide
you
so you emotionally don't get so caught
up into it uh but
come up with a dollar range that you're
gonna buy don't let the bank or mortgage
company
tell you how much you're going to spend
you need to do that on your own yeah
well you've done such a great job she
really has i mean
you've saved up a hundred thousand
dollars most people don't have a
thousand dollars that's exactly she's
got a hundred she's been intentional she
really is pretty impressive well she's
from kentucky
dave she's she's smart i'm just gonna
put that out there
are you yeah you're just gonna you think
i'm just gonna leave it lay there i
think you will
maybe not maybe not we can fight on air
it's
okay for us to battle
[Laughter]
i'm just gonna laugh all the way into
the commercial break that's all i'm
gonna do
but seriously people out there i know
okay here you go
i know mortgage rates are low and
everyone's getting house fever and
you're getting tempted
but listen to me don't let interest
rates determine when you make this move
the goal is not to buy a home the goal
is to own that bad boy
outright so you stay in control of you
and your
thing what she's done she's done that
she really hasn't she's sitting there on
a hundred thousand dollars
she easily could have been shopping with
a ninety thousand dollar household
income
for a three or four hundred thousand
dollar house easily yeah and instead
she's
questioning whether she ought to buy a
100 000 one bedroom
that means her heart's right her head's
right that's right and i don't care
where she's from she's acting smart she
is
smart
doesn't matter where she's from we're
gonna give her credit
oh well done well done yeah a home
prices um people you know
getting the impulse fever this
built up thing inside of your spirit
that is
forcing you and your emotional mind to
buy the largest purchase you're gonna
make
yeah this is a recipe for stupidity it
really is
and this is how people get burnt is
doing this kind of stuff so she's
she's being very very smart way to go
cindy great job
chris hogan ramsey personality and i
will be back
right here on the ramsey show
[Music]
so
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today i am dave ramsey
your host thank you for joining us open
phones at eight two five
five two two five luke is with us in
green bay hi luke welcome to the dave
ramsey show
thank you good afternoon dave and chris
sure a question for you today is
regarding umbrella insurance my wife and
i
a few years ago got a one million dollar
umbrella policy liability
and just curious if there's a certain
net worth where we should look at
adding to it on to two and three and
four million as you go along or
is there a certain ratio that you can
say you kind of have a rule of thumb for
well it starts to get ridiculous when
you get above 5 million
the bargain is 1 million you couple 100
bucks you can buy 1 million umbrella
but above 5 million you start to get
ridiculous um
i mean i have found a 10 million that's
decent i think i've got 10 right now
but i also have the dave ramsey problem
i mean if i bump into somebody they're
gonna be going
oh i'm okay what's your name dave ramsey
oh god you know and so
all of a sudden you know it's like i got
a big target on my butt right so
um i went ahead and picked up an extra
level of it but i don't know that i
would necessarily recommend that
anything above 5 million
what i do tell you to do when you get
above the million
need i mean if you're starting to sit on
a net worth of um
uh you know north of three to five
million dollars and that kind of a thing
you're starting to worry million dollars
probably not enough
you really need to start looking at
other risk management things you can do
then and that's starting to
put assets into llc's
and trusts and so forth i
personally do not own a single thing
anymore
i don't even own my cars my cars are in
llc's
and that's all from a risk management
standpoint that the owner of the car is
the only person that can
only only entity that could get sued if
something happened
the individual only way i could get sued
personally is if i had
committed a criminal act and they could
they could pierce it then but
but um so like my one of my farms is in
one llc
this building is in a trust uh
and so on i don't personally own
anything and that way
if someone falls over in one of those
properties or something happens around
one of those
items they can only if you lost the
lawsuit they could only take the assets
in that entity entity that's right and
you bring up the statement risk
management
which is huge because you can work so
hard to build wealth
but if you don't protect it the right
way with an umbrella policy which all
that is folks is
it's another layer of coverage over your
automobile and your homeowners
and so it's just like an umbrella that
you'd walk outside with it's that
extra layer of protection and dave said
it a million dollar policies a couple
hundred dollars a year
yeah and so you can get that in place
but the llc and the trust
they've are crucial things for people to
get set up well and
what you're gonna find is is that when
you get north of five million dollars in
net worth
if you're being wise and watching
everything there's two things to get
that start three things to start to get
very complicated your taxes
uh your risk management portfolio
meaning you start buying things in the
name of something else
and uh uh your estate plan
and the three of those things work
together uh you need to have the
entities built in such a way that they
serve the estate plan
but also serve risk management and so
that that's where
you know you're going to start to spend
some money on defense
yes and on diligence to keep the
government's hands off to keep a target
off your butt that kind of stuff but
you know it's such a small dollar very
competitive very few times do i
would i suggest it would be highly
unusual for me to suggest more than a 5
million
umbrella an umbrella only covers
liability too it doesn't cover anything
else so it's not it's not covering the
property itself you get
covered with traditional insurance yeah
but the umbrella it just attaches to the
liability limits on the top of your car
policy the top of your liability limits
on your car policy the top of the
liability limits on your homeowner's
policy
extends them out another million dollars
and at 250 bucks somewhere around there
all kinds of everyday millionaires out
there so if this is something that rings
true for you
i want you to go to daveramsey.com and
click on the insurance elp
and start to have that conversation like
this is the time to get those things in
place
yep sean is in bloomington indiana hey
sean welcome
to the ramsay show hi dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
yeah so my wife and i are in a very
unique situation
uh these past couple weeks she works for
an esop company
and they just recently got bought out by
another company so all the employees are
being paid out
in their vested shares wow
so my question is we have the option to
take out
a distribution up to 40 of the
payouts of the vested shares and my
question is do we take some of that out
to pay off all of our debt including the
house and then roll over the rest
in the 401k option that they're
providing
with the company or um should we just
roll everything over into the 401k
so it is all pre-tax is that what you're
saying
um no the tap you will start to pay the
taxes
on on the vested shares but um yeah
and so you can't roll it into a 401k
then if it's not pre-taxed it can't be
rolled into a 401k
um yeah they're based on the paperwork
here
um they're giving us the option to
um i guess move it into a 401k
i i'm still looking at all the paperwork
here but yeah i double checked it
because
typically what they would do sean in
that scenario they would allow you to
take what you own in stock and then
purchase
new stock of the new company
okay like it may not be a traditional
401k
but just double check that but i'm going
to tell you buddy
how much debt do you guys owe on right
now outside of your home
uh we all want two vehicles
how much money is this transfer gonna be
worth
it's 1.477 million
this is her part correct
wow i love it congratulations woo-hoo
seriously we feel like that we've won
the lottery yeah
okay here's what you need to do you
don't need to ask two goobs on the radio
you need to get some tax advice
okay i want you to get some detailed tax
advice because there's too much money
involved here
i can't tell exactly what you've got
from
the way you're describing it and i'm
afraid i'm going to mess you up as far
as taxes
number one i want to get the money out
of that single stock
as fast as i can into mutual funds
now you can do that inside of a 401k
inside of a rollover to an
ira or if you've got the ability to just
take the money out
and only pay the taxes on the gain uh
i can't tell what what is available to
you to shelter it
so what i would do if i were in your
shoes let's play this through
let's pretend this is pre-tax because it
sounds like it may be
okay and they're going to convert it to
stock and then i'm going to convert that
stock
into mutual funds inside the 401k
as fast as i can if you can move it
instead of the 401k into an individual
traditional ira with no taxes i'm going
to do that
with the bulk of this and i'm going to
pull out
400 grand and just pay taxes on it
because i think there's not going to be
penalties on it
and pay off your house and your cars
what's your home mortgage
uh we currently owe 126 000.
okay so 200 grand plus some taxes
gets you out of debt 100 right correct
out of 1.7 i'm definitely doing that
unless you're getting hit with the 10
penalty plus your tax rate and i don't
think you are
i think you're gonna get taxed at a
capital gains rate with no
i again you're going to have to get some
professional tax advice because i'm
going to screw this up
but yes i unless you're getting
absolutely
hammered on the withdrawal then i would
pull enough out to be debt-free and i
would roll the rest of it into mutual
funds
into the 401k and i would move it into
some in an individual ira
rollover if i can get with one of the
smart investor pros
and get online and get with one of our
tax pros if you don't have one in your
back pocket both of them are ill
or the elp for taxes and the smartvestor
pro for investing they both can tell you
exactly what you've got because i can't
tell how this esop was set up i can't
either
and i want everybody else to calm down
out there because this is not how these
normally play out
this is the best version of this story
well it's an employee stock option
program
i mean he stopped and the thing just
went bananas it did
they got lucky wonderful but don't leave
your money in the new company stock any
longer than you have to
run uber high risk here i want you to
get out of that and get into some
diversified investments
where you can calm your risk down and
that way this money's gonna still be
sitting there that's right
congratulations that's so
thrilling this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
matt and jamie are with us in sioux city
iowa hey
guys how are you we're good dave how are
you
better than i deserve i see on my screen
you're debt-free congratulations
thank you we're excited how much have
you paid off
eighty one thousand two hundred forty
three dollars and ninety three cents
love it how long did that take roughly
16 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time
um so our primary jobs have us right
about 50 take home
um and then the um four or five side
hustles that we did throughout that time
brought us up to about 80.
wow four to five you guys are after it
goodness what kind of uh debt was the 81
000
uh so it was all student loans and 95 of
it was
probably me so how long you guys been
married
just about a year and a half okay so you
get married and you started on this boom
just like that huh
pretty much when we were doing marriage
prep
my sister and her husband who have been
married for a few years
they introduced us to you um so we
started um
you know reading your books listening to
podcasts and we were engaged um and then
the day after the wedding we got home
and drained my bank account um and
really just kind of started
wow went after it very cool so the side
hustles left and side hustles to the
right
what was the most lucrative per hour the
best
side hustle um i would say probably
i bartended a couple different places i
would say the marina bar
or even during the pandemic once things
were shut down
and matt and i were both working from
home i started quilting
and doing like t-shirt quilts and baby
quilts and things like that
and i got faster at it so that turned
into pretty good
you know per hour wage that is fantastic
uh it and looking at this so jamie did
you kick-start this
or did you guys kind of both come
together and agree
we both really agreed um i think matt
um because he was he was kind of the one
that was bringing in the student loans
um
he got pretty intense about it and we
started
um you know even though we were still
engaged and we hadn't combined our
finances you know we were
doing the monthly budget we were
tracking everything we were spending
um and so that was kind of um how i had
lived i mean i worked
40 50 hours a week during undergrad so i
didn't have student loans
um and so once we got married we were
really on the same page which made it a
lot easier yeah that's fantastic i mean
when you guys are in this thing together
you know people rowing in the same
direction get to destinations faster
so very proud of you who encouraged you
all during this
during this time um i would definitely
say like jamie said her sister and her
brother
both of our parents were very much in
tune with it as well they were big
supporters of us
and um you know just her and i like
like she said we got very serious about
this our first year
we did not live with heat or ac um one
day
it got to 49 degrees one night and we
just we powered through it and now we
are currently living
in a funeral home to save on rent so
we're
we're all in on this whole thing so it's
it's pretty pretty crazy
we got quite a story to tell wait a
minute here hold on just a minute
are you all working at this funeral home
or living there
um a little bit of both that's i guess
you can count that as one of my five
jobs um it's you know it's just kind of
as needed
basis on whatever they need help with
but um i
it was one of my gigs when i was in
college and then when we moved back to
the area
you know friends of ours had run this
funeral home and they said hey
do you want to live there in exchange
for some extra hours that you're going
to help us so
yeah you know hard to turn that down
well
okay no it's not
hey you all are all in for sure yeah
you'll be telling your grandkids
yeah we lived in the funeral home that's
how we
there's only there's only been one
really ghost story
so we're doing pretty well for having
lived there for a year and a half so
we're happy with it
wow that's one too many but i'm good
yeah all right
i'm even more impressed with you all now
i was before but now
i think i think jamie comes from a
family that believes in working really
hard
yeah i mean her family's been farmers
for a long time and when i got there it
was
um like jamie had already had this
figured out on what
what work is and what you need to get
done and um
we need to spend money you need to have
money and we
don't do much of the spending so that's
kind of what i learned and
um yeah now we're now we're killing it
yeah so what do you guys tell people
the keys to getting out of debt are um
i would say um to be on the gentle edge
of just
grow up i would say you have to stop
buying into this myth
of instant gratification um i think
that's something that our society has
kind of manipulated people into thinking
that you know everything is just right
there and it's
kind of what you said just do what feels
good um you know you have to kind of get
over that
and work towards something bigger and
and get rid of that you know instant
gratification
um that was the biggest thing i think
for us because there would be weekends
that we would work
40 45 hours in a three-day span and we
would make seven or eight hundred
dollars but
i didn't want to go to dairy queen to
spend six dollars to cap off the weekend
like
we were just kind of so um you know
gazelle intense that you know we just
really didn't want to break from that
um and we really looked kind of beyond
that fleeting moment
well done well adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good
you're right
yeah that's just absolutely vital so
well done
how does it feel now that you're there
i mean it's incredible we're starting to
you know jamie's going to go to school
here again
pretty soon and we're already cash
flowing that um
you know it's just been part of the
process she got her master's degree we
cashflowed our wedding our honeymoon i
mean it's just that's how we're going to
start doing things and continue to do
things so it's incredible that we don't
have to pay
student loans every single month that
that chunk of change is coming out
automatically it's it's awesome to see
that
the hard work we put in is staying in
our bank account and we get to use it
how we want to
yeah proud of y'all very proud of you
well done
well hey we're going to give you a copy
of chris's book everyday millionaires
and i'm also going to give you some
tickets to the
friday night valentine's weekend
special where john deloney and rachel
cruz are doing a money and marriage
event
so we're going to give you some tickets
for that you guys you guys need a night
off i'm just saying wow
yeah weekends with bernie and everything
oh my gosh unbelievable wow
so you guys are impressive so well done
you're absolute rock stars i'm proud of
you
very proud of you all right it is matt
and jamie 81
000 dollars paid off in 16 months making
50 to
80. and uh there's a great place to go
when you're broke
to work they proved it well done count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it i love it wow all right
madison pick up and get him a copy of
chris's book plus get him a copy of this
upcoming event
it is this coming friday february the
12th the
marriage and money event with rachel
cruz and dr john deloney
talking to you about the money and
marriage connection the communication
one of the things we have found over the
years for those of you that are married
it is absolutely vital that you're on
the same page
with money it changes your relationship
it changes the probability of your
wealth building
occurring everything it's only thirty
dollars
twenty dollars was the early bird ticket
so it's only thirty dollars a ticket
and uh you can enjoy this live stream
and uh this coming friday at 7 p.m
central no matter what your marriage
looks like right now we can help you
achieve better unity and
communication at the special valentine's
edition
of money and marriage streaming live to
your home
friday february 12th at 7 p.m and again
dr john deloney rachel cruz one thing
for sure if those two are speaking there
will be
humor oh they're going to have fun the
two of them are
good they're just funny we may have to
be there to make sure they do what
they're doing
yeah we gotta hit the stuff they just
get to cutting up but listen i don't
know anybody else that does that stuff
no not you and i
we are straight laced that's right we
stay with the business always
we never we never stray never weekends
with bernie
twice or two or three times an hour
here's the deal if you're a part of
ramsay plus
you better get on over there and reserve
your seat because you get a chance to
check it out for fun free
it's a part of your membership man check
it out this is how it works
date night this is how it works i love
it
this is the ramsey chef
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsay show thank you for
joining us the phone number is triple
eight
eight two five five two two five adam is
in valdosta georgia
hi adam how are you hey dave hey chris
thanks for taking my call
sure how can we help i'm in a position
where
um with my career i'm trying to go back
to school and get a degree
to further my career and i'm in a
position where
it's possible that i may have to go into
debt
to get this degree um
with my career classes can be
transferred over into credit into this
specific
university online university and
there's no way i this is the only one
that
moves all the classes i've ever taken
into
college credits so i'm trying to
struggle because i'm i'm doing my debt
snowball
i'm struggling with handling the debt
that i have
and trying to stay debt-free for my
degree
and what's your degree what's your
degree field i'm trying to get a
bachelor's or four-year degree in
business administration
okay and how much do you lack
um i have depending on how many
credit hours my classes for my career
move over
i have only my core classes so i'm
fairly fresh
into it so you got like three years of
work left
yeah i mean right and i could cut i
could cut that in half
almost if i go to this university
because it'll transfer all my career
stuff over
so you'd have a year and some change
left you be in your senior year or
late in your junior year correct okay
all right and what do you do for a
living i'm a firefighter
okay how old are you i am 26.
okay and so the business degree does
what for you
it allows me for it's one of our uh
requirements for promotion in the future
as a firefighter you need a business
degree uh
as a higher level administration level
uh chief oh actually okay yeah
it's a further down on my career path
yeah
all right and how many years before you
would be eligible
for that um position if you had this
degree
if i had the degree i would say
[Music]
roughly five to ten years
it's rough to say but at least five yeah
okay and um how many colleges are in
valdosta
um three i believe
okay yep three yeah and you're
the one you're looking at though is
online correct
not one of those three no uh this is the
only
this university or the online university
is the only one that
moves all my clients i got that part i
got that
part have you talked to all three of the
others
i have
okay because they are much cheaper than
the online
yes a fourth aren't they
uh roughly yeah yeah so that's what
you're doing you're either gonna
go over there and talk one of them into
this
and uh appeal i mean sit down in the
president's office just stroll your butt
in there
and sit down and go i'm getting ready to
move everything to an online and pay too
much
for this degree because you guys won't
transfer these credits so we've got to
figure out something because this is
crazy i would rather
keep the money here in our community i'm
a firefighter here in this community
i'd rather keep the money here in the
community and support our local college
and
it's better for me to say i graduated
from this local community and it is by
the way
right yeah you're not going to go into
debt and go online
matter of fact i think the online idea
is just a bad idea because i think
you're paying way too much for the
stinking degree
that you don't need for seven years
right so i would just nix that and i i
think you just got to do some
politicking on the transfer
because the thing is these are small
colleges this isn't like you're trying
to go
the freaking harvard and get them to
waive your you know accept your credits
right this is valdosta state or whatever
it is for god's sakes
i mean it's not like it's it's not a i'm
not putting it down i'm you'll probably
get a great education there
but my point is you'll have access to
people probably that have an open mind
oh by the way they they actually want
students need students
they definitely i'm going to go in there
and find out what the appeals process is
or
who i have to appeal to or who who needs
to stroke a
agreement an executive order waiving
this or i don't know how it works even
i wish dr john was here because he would
know because it baffles me because even
with a community college they will take
their credits not give you the grades
some
some of them but i mean i'm going to
communicate adam take the opportunity or
the thought of going into debt off the
table exactly that's what i want you to
do
just because right now you've got that
looking like it's the only option
to you and it's really not i'd much
rather you go
have that conversation go low and slow
as you're going part time
and it take you longer to get the degree
with avoiding debt we got 43 million
people walking around
with 1.7 trillion in student loan debt
you
you don't want to go there yeah and all
and a percentage of them whining at the
top of their lungs expecting the
government to forgive their debt now
um we've got the um the lefties you know
going bananas on this stuff now
and so oh we should all have it forgiven
we should know and so you know i'm going
to be telling you
no no no no no no now the other question
that i would
bring into play here
i understand that you need the knowledge
pieces
to be an administrator in a leadership
position that high that
the the business leadership but um
i might even challenge that the degree
is a hundred percent a prerequisite for
you moving up into those roles
[Music]
i think if you could exhibit and show
the knowledge that was in place
right you probably might you'd be
eligible for that
as well i i actually have never run into
that before but that doesn't mean
that you're not correct i'm just saying
i haven't run into it and so it does
make sense it's logical sense that to be
in an administrative role as senior
chief of the chief of uh
fire chief for the whole county or
whatever that kind of a thing that you
would need some
uh organizational administrative
uh skill sets that you would get in a
four-year business degree that's right
that's logical to me
i'd even have the conversation with the
chief there to find out can i enroll in
the national guard
well or will they pay for it yeah i mean
i want to have the conversation on this
to find out and understand it more
uh but adam thanks for reaching out
buddy that's very cool you can hear it's
heavy on your heart you need some more
options and to have some conversations
and keep gathering information the the
trick is as chris said take the debt off
the table it's not an option
and then from there what are we going to
do we've got to find another way to get
this
goal accomplished and that's what i keep
poking out around the edges here what
are the options to still accomplish the
goal
with no debt yeah and and you know
either cash flowing it
national guard fire department ships in
i don't care it doesn't matter to me i
hate that you would pay
four times more because you can't get
the local college to accept the transfer
credits yeah
which is illogical by the way on top of
that so it means you got a good case as
far as i'm concerned
brenda is with us in oklahoma city hi
brenda welcome to the ramsey show how
can we help
hi thank you um i want you to rethink if
you would
buying personal defense insurance
because um i'm single i live alone
and i don't live in the best
neighborhood
and i've already bought it in all
actuality
and my son is a firm believer in you
he's coming home next month he's helping
me
go through my budget because he's
already succeeded with yours
what are you paying for this oh 179 a
year
and you make he's gonna go um
right oh about 30 000 a year that's a
lot of money for you
and so basically if you pull your
handgun out and shoot a bad guy this is
supposed to protect you
it would because well i actually know
the
company yeah it's a really good company
there's there are some legitimate
companies in that space and there are
some companies that cover about half of
what they say they're going to cover too
so um i
mean i live in tennessee i i'm a handgun
enthusiast
i collect guns yeah uh i carry every day
um i don't have it and i make a lot more
than thirty thousand dollars
uh but the biggest insurance i've got is
i'm going to run
because i'm not pulling that gun out
right i'm going to run
right i'm going to run like like my
head's on fire yeah
so i i if you want to buy it it's okay
with me
i mean it's not the other world it's a
lot of money for you honey
and i might think about spending 179 on
moving
um you know some other things like that
there's some other things to look at but
i
you have the you give the impression as
if this is somehow going to fix
everything if you shoot somebody it's
not it's not it's going to ruin your
[Applause]
[Music]
life
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host chris hogan ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five eric starts off this hour
in erie pennsylvania hi eric how are you
hi i'm doing well dave how are you doing
better than i deserve how can we help
so i'm 19 years old i'm a full-time
college student and i've just started
um listening to your show i just got my
car paid off so i have
zero debt and i got into college with a
lot of scholarships and
i'm also very very fortunate to have a
college fund
so i will be graduating with no debt um
i've been working
hard throughout high school and college
since i was 15
and i have about four thousand dollars
saved up between my savings and
investments
and my question is should i start
contributing to my roth ira or should i
wait until i'm out of college and i've
started my career
man you're a rock star well done yeah
you're very well done
congratulations i'm proud of you man
very well done
um here's the thing you have plenty of
time after graduation to begin your
retirement
investing so if you graduate from school
get your first gig
your 401k roth there or your roth iras
and start from there on
you're go and you keep doing that from
22
until you're through your working
lifetime you're going to be a
multi millionaire plus you are not
afraid of hard work and you've been very
intentional with your money
very wise beyond your years and so if
you don't get crazy
you're going to be a multi multi multi
millionaire because it's the way you're
wired up is
you're heading in that direction already
the
best insurance that you have the best
income
is for you to finish your degree and
finish it without debt
as long as the degree is something
that's applicable and there's a job
market for it what are you studying
[Music]
um i'm studying communication sciences
and disorders and i'm going to go for a
master's degree in speech language
pathology
phenomenal excellent excellent so
that is going to afford you an excellent
income would you agree
yes okay so um translation
the money that you would put into a roth
the end of good mutual funds
the money it would make in the next
three years
compared to what you are going to be
worth as a result of graduating with
this degree
is is not even on the same chart you
are a much better investment than a roth
in mutual funds are
yep to finish your studies now i
understand you've got it mapped out
with scholarships and with a college
fund that you're going to go through
debt free
i heard that clearly and i heard that
you have twenty four thousand dollars
it wouldn't make me mad in other words
if you didn't start your roth
until after graduation and instead
ended up with i'm going to make up a
number 50 000 bucks in an account when
you graduate
you can start investing some of that
money then you can use it for transition
into your new career and move cities and
all that kind of a thing
have a fully funded emergency that's
like an insurance
policy to ensure that eric graduates
debt-free
yeah and eric what about the masters are
you going to be paying for that or is
your college fund going to pay for it
um my college fund is going to be paying
for it it's great
i'm actually in a five-year program so
i've already been
accepted into the master's degree
program and i know exactly how much it's
going to cost
not bad also roll over
so um i will be graduating 100
debt free well i'm proud of you buddy
and here's the beauty of it
while your college friends might be
eating ramen noodles you can upgrade
okay you got some money uh but be smart
and like dave said
graduate have 50 000 sitting there ready
for you to jump start life
and be just hyper intentional moving
forward then eric even if you wanted to
park some
of it into an investment say like a uh
an index fund okay an s p 500 fund a no
load fund something like that
if you want to park some of it there and
begin some investing
that's okay i just wouldn't put it in a
retirement product
like a roth or a 401k because
my big goal for you is to finish this
wonderful track you put yourself on
and uh man you've gotten some really
good coaching and advice
and you you know you're a very very
sharp young man great job buddy
excellent excellent work angel is in
tampa florida hi angel how are you
hey good afternoon david chris uh thank
you for taking my call
sure how can we help well i have two
questions
one i want to start with i have an rv
that i purchased uh and i'm on my baby
step two
and i it's i owe 255 it's probably worth
45
so my question is in baby step 2 do i
just get away or find a way to get rid
of it
even if i have to carry or maintain some
kind of
you know balance yes
okay yeah what do you make a year
uh 72. yeah yeah this thing's insane
what's the payment on it oh it's nuts
it's
500. yeah yeah forever 500 months yeah
so what yeah you you're gonna end up
with a ten thousand dollar unsecured
loan at your credit union or your bank
to cover the deficit that you're in at
and because you've got to cover that
difference in order to sell it and get
the title correct
correct or the rv company okay or if the
rv company will carry it for you
yeah then i would let you do that as
well but yeah you need to get rid of it
and
you're gonna have to cover the
difference so but it's better to be ten
thousand dollars in death and fifty five
hey
absolutely and the five hundred dollars
you've been used to paying
that's gonna allow you to again you're
gonna go to that snowball route
make minimum payments on everything but
the small one and once you chop that
down you're coming on down
and angel you're gonna change your kind
of financial situation
uh with that but go talk to a credit
union or your bank
because this has to be unsecured in
order to release the title from the rv
company
yeah or if the whoever you've got the rv
loan with if they will agree to just let
you sign a note for the difference
if you've already got the loan over at
your local credit union for instance or
over at your local bank you can get them
to just
allow you to sign a note for the
difference and and you pay payments on
that and put it into your debt snowball
but again it's easier to get out of ten
thousand than 55
and and owning a 55 000 vehicle that's
going down in value like a rock
sitting in your driveway when you make
75 is a mathematical
using it twice a year crazy land yeah
no it's got to go you gotta get rid of
it you don't own any rvs
i don't why uh i i
i waste my money on other things
i do waste money i mean because i own
two boats and two seadoos that right
there will offset us
rv right and so i mean i got two ski
boats but
but again they're a very small
percentage not only of my net worth
but of my income but they are also used
and and well
um the one of them when i bought it i
bought one of them new no no i meant
they're used throughout the year oh
you're always
i'm you know riding around behind that
boat all the time but yeah but but i
mean he may be using the rv he
don't know he's not using it but um the
abode and rv all these things are toys
right
and there's nothing wrong with having a
side-by-side or you know getting a
snowmobile or whatever it is you want to
get this a toy
but all the things that you number one
you'll pay cash for it and
all the things that you own with wheels
motors on them they go down in value so
they should
add up to no more than half your annual
income because otherwise you have too
much juice tied up and stuff going down
instead of yeah
that's not good pretty simple math
formula this is the day
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org backslash
[Music]
budget
[Music]
so
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality
is my co-host today thank you for
joining us this is the ramsay show
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five tony is with us in sioux
falls south dakota hi tony welcome to
the
ramsey show how can we help good
afternoon gentlemen thanks for taking my
call
sure hey my question is i get a uh my
company leases a vehicle back from me
i'm currently on steps four five and six
and it's about eight hundred and fifty
dollars a month
and it the over the last ten years i've
used that fund i've just put it in a
savings account and
gained zero interest on it to buy my
vehicle with cash every time
and i'm just looking at i'm wondering
what to do with that money
this time around if it's a money market
mutual funds
savings account what's the best option
well if you put it into a mutual fund
you stand the probability of it going
down in value not
just up right correct and i know you say
if they're not going to leave it in five
years and not go into a mutual fund yeah
um this last this last time it was
actually about five and a half
years when i used the funds well i mean
you could you could split it up and you
could put half into a
s p 500 and a half into a money market
and then you're not putting it
all at risk of going down if you want to
try to let it earn a little bit
um the trick is that the system is
what's going to save your butt
not the fact that you had it invested
okay how much money are what you're
talking you're talking about you said
800 a month and you're putting it all
aside for car replacement right
correct it's about ten thousand dollars
a year and at the end of the uh
i usually run the vehicles to about two
hundred two hundred and fifty i'd like
to run them as long as they can
and uh let's say over that five year
period of time then let's say it
averaged twenty five thousand dollars
because fifty thousand in five years so
it averages
median the median point is 25k and so if
you make 10 percent
on 25k that's 2500.
uh which does not impact a fifty
thousand dollar situation that much
okay so what you earn on this money is
not as important as the fact that you
have a system
to keep yourself from going into debt
so it would be okay to earn nothing then
as long as i'm
continuing with yeah because it's the
the investment
but if you were going to leave it alone
20 years and you left it at one percent
well that'd be
ludicrous right yeah yeah and tony i
mean you've got an opportunity to be
able to put half of that aside for car
replacement you could throw the other
half your cedro on four five and six
you could throw that toward the mortgage
you know the point is you want the money
to work for you
don't put any more in this car
replacement fund
then you need to replace the car right
and so whatever the schedule is on that
and again if you want to just just to
dial it up a little bit
move half of it into mutual funds and
into an s p 500 and the other half
just let it ride on a thing i mean
let it ride in a money market account
but but the whatever you earn on it even
if you earn really good money
is not going to substantially change
your life
what is substantially changing your life
is you've been smart enough to avoid
debt
and you have a system to replace these
cars as you after you wear them out and
you are destroying them
because you're the number of miles
you're putting on them i mean you're
just wearing them out and that's uh your
road warrior as part of the cost of
doing business in your world
nothing wrong with that but at least
you've figured out how to admit it
and uh that's pretty cool and you also
figured out the 800
a month doesn't cover all your costs so
uh they're
they're they're giving you some money
but they not giving you a company car
you've been better off with a company
car uh a lot
better off all right dave is with us in
dallas hi dave
welcome to the ramsey show how can we
help hey dave i'm uh
trying to determine whether or not i
should do a deferred income annuity
why would you do that well
my financial person
suggested it because i'm real fearful
fearful of the
other market crash and
she's like well you know if the market
crashes you know the he's losing the
value
of our retirement right now i'm i'm
retired
uh my wife is fixing to retire
i'm 58 how much money started retired at
55 and uh
how much money is it got 2.3
and you're fearful that the market is
going to completely destroy
well not completely but uh you know
half and then if i'm withdrawing
and where in history have you seen it do
that yeah
okay uh you're right you're right uh
or 30 i guess and where in history have
you seen it do that
i thought 2008 was somewhere around
there no it was half
the dow went from 13 to 6 700. okay
and it was back in a year right
and now it's not 6700 or 13. it's 30
000 right correct okay
so unless you have a need for 2.5
million dollars at the bottom of the
market
you would not embrace the 30 loss you
would ride it out wouldn't you
yes even though i'm going to be
withdrawing
you know 10 grand a month which is a
whole 120 000
a year that's not even the growth okay
okay dave listen yes sir listen my
friend
you are an everyday millionaire you have
been intentional in growing this money
you're going to be fine i i listen
the thing is this okay i understand
that the world is unraveling out here in
front of us i'm watching it too
i'm not disagreeing with you about that
but we we
dr daloni talks about when we're in a
crisis situation or when we're in a
situation
facts are our friends not fear
and if the facts say if there's some
actual
facts that indicate that we're going to
have a substantial
market drop and it's going to maintain
and it's going to stay down there
then we would have this discussion i
don't have any of those facts
the only thing i've got is i don't like
the socialist
tendencies that are in dc right now
i don't like the idea of heavy taxation
i don't like what they're going to do to
the economy
uh overall i don't think it's going to
be pleasant but i don't think we're
going to see a market correction of 30
percent
i'm 60 i have pulled zero
out of the market due to my being upset
about the current world that i live in
does that make sense
yes so while i have those emotions i
have to gauge the actual
facts of the history to do that so
all of that said i'm not sure i would do
a deferred income annuity i might do a
variable annuity and a variable annuity
will give you principal protection
and a floor of a minimum gain
or minimum increase in value usually
five percent six percent
and you're invested in vehicles that are
gonna make you ten to twelve
on average but if the market really
tanked you'd have principal protection
and you would have uh uh
you know a floor for the earnings and so
if if that will make you sleep better at
night
you're going to pay an extra fee for
that
variable annuity that you really don't
need it doesn't give you anything that
you need
except that peace of mind that you're
looking for so you're paying for that
now would i move the whole two million
dollars in there absolutely not
but but what i move in your case if you
still
think this through and you still are
worried about it uh
you know then you know you might move
500 700 in there maybe move a third of
your
of your net worth into that it's not a
bad place because you can put it in good
mutual funds you'll still have a similar
growth rate
you're just going to have a higher
expense ratios okay
and when you pull money out of it it's
no longer going to be taxed at
uh well it's it's it's all in 401ks
anyway isn't it
correct yeah you're going to be tax
ordinary income anyway when you come out
but um no oh i'm sorry
right now no mine's not in 401ks
all of mine is or the majority of mine
is in um high rates okay
but if you have non you see you're taxed
at ordinary income when you pull it out
of a traditional ira
and so when you pull it out of this
you're going to be tax ordinary income
too so that doesn't harm you much
if you're dealing with non-retirement
money putting into a variable annuity
you're going to
change from capital gains taxation to
ordinary income taxation which is
something else to consider but that's
not your case yeah
so maybe a third of it dave but the
other thing i would do is i'd spend some
more time learning about history and let
facts be your friends
even though we're scared
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host
thank you for joining us america you're
listening to the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey your host kyle is with
us in
fayetteville north carolina hey kyle how
are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call i got
a quick question about
uh a little bit of extra money that i
got where i should be putting it
i say i should be putting it extra
towards my mutual funds my wife wants to
pay off the rental properties
your wife would be right
so even if i plan on selling those
rental properties when i retire out of
the military in four years
we'll go and sell them now
i could do that okay
but they're they're they're they're
still making me a little bit of money
and so when i retire i think the key
here is a little bit
yeah but kyle think about it that same
mindset you have of wanting to put the
money into mutual funds
for it to be able to grow long-term for
you if you go ahead and sell them now
and take that equity
finish cleaning up whatever debt you
have and now you invest that now you're
on a serious long-term growth plan
yeah here's the thing
you're not really making any money on
these rental properties are you
um not real money i mean i'm making
close to 750 a month off the rentals and
it's paying down the
mortgage and you know building equity
750 minus
vacancy minus repairs
yes yeah so
you know really we're talking about
three or four thousand dollars a year
and you're how far in debt on the rental
properties
uh total it's four 437.
437 thousand dollars worth of risk to
make three thousand dollars a year
that does not make sense when you said a
little bit of money
i knew what you were talking about see i
love real estate
but real estate is not a good investment
the way you've done it
because this is probably it has as much
chance of costing you money
at the end of the story as it does
making you money so i think you're both
going to get your wish i would sell the
rentals
now because i don't think they're a
blessing
and i want you to buy rentals later and
pay cash for them
in your wealth building journey but not
this year and maybe after you get out of
the military and
maybe after you decide where you're
going to settle and all of those kinds
of things but
right now i'm going to go ahead and
invest that money into mutual funds like
you wanted to do yeah kyle thank you for
your service by the way but i knew dave
was about to do a math lesson on you
i knew it because i've been around
enough and i've heard it
and unfortunately you know when we see
it for what it is you see those numbers
the real way
and you start to identify you're only
making about three grand a year
and taking on that level of risk you can
quickly identify that it's not worth it
well there is something that has risen
up
um in the um 20s
the 20 year olds 20 to 30 year olds even
20 to 35 year olds right now
that we're seeing almost on a
moment-by-moment basis in all of our
interactions uh
with you guys out there through
broadcasting and through all the other
ways we interact with you
uh the positive is there's this
tremendous
that this generation whatever we're
calling these 20-somethings
has this tremendous entrepreneurial zeal
in drive
and this this this sense to be
independent it's not greed driven
it's uh initiative it's very positive
it really is it's a wonderful character
attribute you've got that that's how you
got these rental properties
and that drive is causing these
20-somethings
to do two things and oftentimes poorly
because they're doing them too quickly i
did this in my 20s
but i'm a boomer which now is a put down
but it used to be just a demographic but
um
but uh now i've got old man house shoes
you know so there you go
but the uh uh the the this wonderful
zeal this wonderful entrepreneurial zeal
is causing
these 20-somethings to buy real estate
because i got to buy real estate
i'm going to get rich in real estate i'm
going to get rich in real estate man
when i was in my 20s
is when infomercials started oh that was
the beginning of infomercial oh yes
i'm gonna get rich in real estate i'm
gonna get rich in real estate
and uh i grew up in the real estate
business and so i went straight into i'm
gonna get rich in real estate and i did
i
became a millionaire by the time i was
26 and uh the other it's driving this
bitcoin craze it's driving this game
stop crazy yes
yes uh uh the same zeal is driving
people to do these things and to get out
there and i'm gonna turn over i'm gonna
do something i'm
gonna get some i'm gonna and it's not
greed it's the spirit on it
i mean the my discernment says it's not
greed it is
initiative it's it's a positive ambition
but what caused what happened with me
was i bought real estate that i couldn't
afford
i leveraged it i used totally borrowed
money and i ended up with 4 million
worth of real estate that i owed 3
million on so i had a million dollar net
worth
but it wasn't cash flowing and i was
flipping it and it was barely cash
flowing like his is barely cash flowing
this is why i know this math because i
lived it
right because i did the same thing only
i did it with more zeros on the end it
wasn't 400 000 is 4 million
and it took me down because the bank got
uh sold and called our notes
and uh then i and i didn't have any cash
i was not in it they i had all these
assets but there was no cash
[Music]
and when you do that with real estate is
when you're gonna go broke
not when you're gonna make a fortune in
real estate and so real estate that does
not have margin
is not a blessing it's a liability and
investing in things that don't have
margin
or that are a high risk gamble play
is a misuse of your entrepreneurial
ambitious zeal
and so i love the zeal what i want to do
is channel it
with some wisdom and a process some
wisdom
yes and that is slow down a little bit
yeah and pay cash and don't invest
everything you have in super high risk
crap
um i mean and i i know there's stories
of people making money in bitcoin
i know there's stories of people making
money with gamestop
we talked to one here on the other day
i'm not saying it can't happen
but i know stories of people made money
at the roulette wheel too that's right
i know people that made money on wheel
of fortune
but that doesn't mean our jeopardy i've
got personal friends that that won
and they won 50 000 bucks or something
but they didn't change their career to
be game show operators
right and they didn't put everything
they had that didn't push all their
chips to the center of the table on one
hand to cards
and that's what we're doing when we go
into highly leveraged real estate into
businesses with no margin
or high risk investment plays and we act
like it's a freaking game
right because we put all the chips in
the table now if you've got a small
percentage of your chips and you're
going to lose those and it doesn't kill
you that's different i don't even
recommend that but i'm not going to make
fun of you for that
right i am going to call you out on the
other because this this
you know it leads to uh bad critical
thinking that
okay real estate's a good investment so
all real estate no matter how broke i am
is a good investment that's right that's
bad thinking skills
it is and that's what happened with in
the 90s with day trading
uh it's what we're seeing now with
bitcoin and gamestop
uh but i'm going to tell you something
dave i'm getting these callers calling
in these millennials
on my show the chris hogan show that are
saving and investing and following the
plan and the trail
is the foundations course they took in
high school
that they were either financial peace
babies where their parents went through
it
taught them or they went through
foundations and so they've got this
learning foundation literally where
they're thinking and following the
process
yeah it's encouraging i had people you
know
when i'm doing real estate deals i have
people that thought i was a genius
when i was buying all that real estate
um
except the old people and the old people
that had money
kept looking at me going son you're too
leveraged you got no cash
this is going to catch up with you
you're going to get a spanking
you're going to get it and i kept going
oh you're just old you don't understand
this is a proper use of capital markets
and i used all the cash flows
you know i've got great internal rates
of return
i have no cash right no liquidity i
couldn't buy a freaking loaf of bread
you know but i got four million dollars
worth of real estate and so
this idea that you can throw around all
your arrogant little terms and all they
show is your immaturity
they don't show that i'm a dinosaur they
show that you're a child
that's all it shows and so the thing is
use this ambition this movement which is
so positive in this generation
in a slower more methodical cash basis
way
with high margins and then you're going
to learn love real estate
i got a bunch of real estate and i want
you to have some too i just don't want
to have you
there it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well tax season is here
i know that's exciting oh goody dave
thanks for the help the reason i want to
say that listen you got to do your taxes
early
the reason you do them early not in
march or april is because you're going
to be under far less stress and less
stress means less mistakes
plus if you actually owe taxes filing
early means you can start saving
or being ready to file early even if you
need to if you need to save up and wait
until april 15th to actually pull the
trigger on the file you'll at least know
what the target is right
if you need a tax pro you need to get
with one right now
before they get busy you get busy you
know this is the sooner you reach out to
a tax pro the better
and that way your taxes get done way
before the deadline and then you can
decide
a strategy for this year and what you
need to do text
the word tax pro 23789
and we'll hook you up with one of our
tax endorsed local providers
text taxpro one word to
33789 and you'll find a tax pro that
chris and i
and all the ramsey personalities endorse
and think are awesome
seriously clemmy is with us clemmy is in
atlanta georgia is it clemmy is that
correct
yes sorry how can we help hey how you
doing fellas
hey so i've got a question i'm in a job
that i love
and with my uh career trajectory um i
plan on i'm assistant manager at the
retail store
and within the next year or so i'm gonna
bump up to a
store manager and wipe that out for
another five years
and stay with the company and go to um
corporate office after that
but my quandary is that i have
credit card quoted to me and it goes
against everything that i believe
in and i have to push these get stored
credit cards
and i'm having a hard time um
doing my job effectively and also
and and also i don't want that to um
hinder me from moving up within my
company so i'm
at a loss of what to do in this regard
how long you been with him
uh since 2016. so i'm going on five
years
what do you make i'm at 60.
how big a knot is in your stomach
well listening to you every day doesn't
help
[Laughter]
sorry about that brother
my friend i crossed that same path and
here's the reality
it is truly a matter of you coming to
understand that the skill set that
you've been blessed to have
the way that you work the way that you
serve customer service and sales
that same skill set can be used
elsewhere
without you having to have a conflict of
what you believe in
and it's going to require you to have
that thought process
before you gain clarity and i would tell
you what i did was i started to write
down
options where ca where else can i go and
help people
and serve well without having to do
something i don't believe in
and i'm going to tell you in that
industry it's not going to go away
you're not going to be able to miss this
in order to move up you're going to have
to embrace it
and and not only embrace it do it well
so
that's where you're going to have that
crisis of kind of internal conflict
you're going to have to change
industries but that doesn't mean you can
still can't serve people
now here two three things come to mind
one is you've got a detailed
career path laid out in your mind with
this company so
you're not abandoning a 60 000 your job
that you hate
no you're abandoning a dream that you've
had yeah
yeah if you leave this company and
that's going to be very hard to do
that's why this conflict is so real and
i'm not suggesting that you
have to do this on principle you're
calling and saying
that the principles are that you feel
like you're in conflict
so one thing is i think you need to it's
going to take you a little while
and you don't have to panic and you're
not stealing from you're not stealing
bubble gum from little children i mean
this is not
you know you're not you know you're just
doing something that you don't feel good
about that you wouldn't do for your own
kids
you wouldn't do for your mama and you
know so you're violating your conscience
in that regard
and so but but it's not you're not
you're not doing anything illegal you're
not doing anything immoral
uh so i would take my time and
work my way into a new dream
a new career path that uh that i can
begin working on and
so you know embrace some of ken
coleman's materials at kingcoleman.com
and you know the proximity principle
book will give you a copy i'll have
madison pick up and give you a copy
so that's kind of thing one is there's a
real
emotional process that probably is going
to take more than 10 minutes
okay if they came in and said you had to
do something illegal
that would take you about a minute and a
half to walk out the door
right absolutely but but this is not
this is not that situation this is just
a
this is a rub is what this is but it's a
rub it's like chris said it's not going
away
now the second thing is to embrace what
chris's
portion of advice was one of my favorite
books on business that i've ever read is
by our friend rabbi daniel lapin and
it's called thou shall prosper
and rabbi lapin as you can obviously
guess is a jewish orthodox rabbi
and the book is the 10 reasons that
jewish people have had a tendency to
prosper
throughout history beyond the population
that they've been installed in
and so for instance uh three percent of
americans are jewish
67 percent of the forbes 400 is so these
are 10 principles we all want to know
right
those of us that aren't jewish but rabbi
and i have become really good friends
over the years and one of the 10
principles is that over a long period of
time
it is almost impossible for someone to
prosper
doing something that they don't believe
to be
morally correct yes
so it's going to be very difficult over
the next 10 years
for your dream path to actually occur
because you have this other you know
knot
in your stomach and you know and i'm
sorry i put it there but i'm
glad you recognized it i mean i i again
i'm not pounding my fist and yelling
that this company is horrible or
something they're just a retail company
selling credit cards they all do
and my goal is that one day uh enough
americans wake up and realize
that the credit card is basically the
cigarette of the financial world
that companies like this quit doing that
because the public pressure forces them
to like the public pressure is forced to
change in
smoking you know when i was growing up
you could smoke on an airplane
a metal tube with people in it full of
smoke i mean it's just amazing in the
air
it's just and the funniest one was when
they went to no smoking sections
yes as if as if as if the magic you were
exhausted it's like the no p
into the pool i mean you know it's like
it doesn't go to the other end of the
pool come on
and so um you know but anyway that you
know that's what's going to happen if as
we continue to have more and more and
more people understand
that living debt-free is a fabulous way
of doing it it really is and chlamy i'm
going to tell you
that little knot that you have right now
is only going to continue to grow
so i am too but i'm excited for you the
thing that that i got to was that it was
a matter of the lord had something else
for me to do
and so having that awareness as dave
said you do shift the dream
but you do understand that you're still
able to serve people and use the skill
set you've been
blessed to have and that you've polished
and so again
we get ken's book we're going to send
you a copy i want you to read it
but start to lay out options and i'm
proud of you for reaching out and
talking about this
early on it was something i struggled
with before i reached out to a mentor to
discuss
yeah i think the options is a big deal
when you've got a new
dream that is as detailed as your
current dream oh man
oh game changer in a different area
that's not going to cause you these
knots in your stomach yeah
then making the change will be easy
right now the idea of making the changes
going from this
dialed in path to nothing yep and that's
not a jump anybody can make emotionally
if you're wise
your emotions will stop you from doing
that and they should so take your time
and let's get a new dream detailed out
a new path that says i'm going to work
here and then i'm going to be a store
manager and then i'm going to be
original manager and then i'm going to
work in the home office and whatever it
is i mean
you had it laid out i mean you got it
dialed in and
uh but i i wish i could tell you that
the big box
whatever it is uh retailer home depot
they'll wake up uh lowe's uh whoever it
is
you know walmart whoever it is i don't
know who it is
that i wish i could tell you they were
going to quit pedaling credit cards soon
enough for your dream to come true but
they're not
nope they're not um tarzan we're going
to keep working on them at ramsay though
yeah we are
until we bother them enough that enough
people start to realize that i think we
can change
and create a whole movement i think we
are we are we are going to create a home
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host chris hogan ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two
five jacob is with us in danbury
connecticut hi jacob welcome to the day
to the ramsey show how can we help
hey dave chris uh thanks for having me
how are you guys better than we deserve
how can we help
um just got a question about a 401k
investment
retirement investment uh right now i
have a traditional 401k and i'm looking
to go to a roth 401k
i just have a question on the best way
to do that if i have to do it all at
once with the taxes or
if there's a steps i can take to kind of
cut down on the amount of
i have to pay out yeah well the first
thing is just stop doing
new except roth let all your new
contributions be roth from this point
forward that's step one
okay now how much is in your 401k in the
traditional
uh about 50 000 right now okay and what
baby step are you on
i am on data stuff four okay then i
would not
convert the 50 000 until after your home
is paid off
okay because it's going to create about
12 000 in taxes
and i would rather use those 12 000 for
your five or six baby step
but later on when you're in baby step
seven and you scratch up some extra cash
then yeah go ahead and flip it uh flip
it on over into the roth at that point
but it won't hurt anything for it to sit
there and grow as traditional
for a couple of years while you get the
house paid off
okay um i i do have another question
about
mutual funds um right now i do have
a portfolio it's kind of a slow growth
uh i'm just wondering what the best
mutual fund that you would recommend to
invest in non-retirement
non-retirement why would you have
non-retirement
um i don't know if if it's something
that i may
need to pull out of it or how much is in
it
i have about 70 000.
what's the balance on your home
about 70 huh i think we just found a use
for
it jacob did you feel that
that was a seismic shift right there for
you buddy
you have an advocate what do you make a
year
uh well this is actually the first year
with a bunch of overtime
i just pulled in about 120. way to go
man
and your debt-free house and everything
i'm so proud of you
game changer jacob yeah seriously
brother
hey man cash it out pay off your house
now let's take that house payment
and let's uh save up twelve thousand
dollars and convert the rest of that
401k to a roth and then let's start
maxing everything out
and uh then let's just start piling up
some cash and being unreasonably
outrageously generous
you are so cool man he is seriously i
mean a young man that has listened
and followed the principles uh is about
100
desperate i mean for the most part
mostly you know but
now he's got a chance to kind of right
the ship and get himself from moving in
the right direction
so for clarification for those of you
that are just kind of in the middle of
you know what a baby step is but you're
not sure about the nuances
whatever money you have in anything
that is not in a retirement account
should be liquidated and used for
whatever step
you are on yes step one's a thousand
dollars two is debt free everything but
the house three is an emergency fund
four is fifteen percent of your income
going into retirement five is kids
college
if that's if that's applicable if not we
head straight on to six and pay off the
house that's how i
did that right but non-retirement
accounts dave can look like what
a brokerage account a mutual fund
investment seventy thousand dollars with
a seventy thousand dollar mortgages
an inheritance all of these things yeah
yeah the money is sitting there from you
got some stock your grandpa gave you you
got
seven thousand dollars in savings bonds
yeah granny gave you you've got
five gold coins that you don't that you
don't even know how you got them or why
you got them or
i don't know what it is what have you
got that is just sitting around it's an
investment
use it for the baby step that you're on
because the
shortest distance between where you are
today and wealthy and outrageously
generous is
walking those baby steps exactly and as
quickly
as you possibly can don't change the
recipe okay
any times people tell me chris you know
i'm following baby steps ish
i'm doing ramsay-ish i'm like stop doing
ish and do
it yeah follow it to a t we've had
millions of people get help
why are you overthinking the wheel it
works
hey we're even walking with our thousand
team members this year
yeah our internal vision for the year
is to walk the talk and so everybody's
going through financial peace university
again
we're dialing in so that our own team
members are not doing ish
that's right and uh we're even doing
t-shirts issues of wish
hogan's got hogan saying on the t-shirt
issues of wish i like it
but seriously got an opportunity right
now where you are
uh to make a decision and if you're not
a part of ramsey plus i'm telling you
right now get over there
we are adding more information and more
content at all times
you have an opportunity to get connected
with the events that we have
via live stream because you're a member
of ramsey plus
so text the word trial to 33789
again the trial is the word text that to
33789
and come on in yeah if you're brand new
the thing is that he he's right that
we've got
this whole thing we just installed it's
in about in the last six months or so
where the first 90 days we give you
small
consistent wins not just the baby steps
but every little detail
leading up into a baby step small
consistent wins these add up to big
results
and better habits and that means you're
going to get where you want to be faster
so free trial by texting
the word trial 23789
now if you're a member by friday night
we've got the money and marriage event
friday night and it
is 30 if you want to watch it as a live
stream rachel cruz and
dr john dolone talking about marriage
and money it'll be fun funny and
informative uh great holla a great
valentine's day gift but if you're a
member ramsey plus
it's free most of our live streams are
free to ramsay plus members
in addition to financial peace
university in addition to premium
version of
every dollar all of that's all wrapped
up there to make sure you get
what you need and that we're able to
walk with you and show you how to do
that but the trick is
there's kind of a spillover effect you
know like one of those water wheels
coming around as the water
fills up one area it moves one more time
spills out and that's how the baby steps
work
it does any of the water that you've got
you put it in that bucket
yeah until that bucket's full and it
spills over the next one move on
and then any other water you get whether
it's from your budget or the gold coins
in your safe
or you're to sell i don't know grandpa's
whatever
i don't know what it is this thing
you've been hanging on to it really is
not an asset it's just sitting over
there on its butt looking at you
and the only thing we don't do is we
don't cash out retirement to do that
because of the penalties and the taxes
are so heavy
and it makes it just it takes the fun
out of it you got a great opportunity
change your future change your mindset
and if you change your mindset
i'm telling you you can change your life
yeah so come over to ramsey plus check
it out
jacob's in a great place yes he is he's
debt free house and everything you just
helped him
if he does what we told him to do he
better follow the directions today jay
right now don't make us come to
connecticut
please no it's cold i can't go up there
i can't go up please don't make me nope
i'll text people
please i don't i'll do anything jacob
i would almost pay off your house to
keep from coming not really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
we invite your calls at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you save even more use the magic word
the promo code ramsey
all right today's question comes from
dave in kentucky
uh he says i lost my wife in december of
2020.
my goodness i have an eight-year-old
that will start receiving survivor
benefits
of 858 dollars per month from social
security
by the time she reaches 18 the total of
those payments will be around a hundred
thousand dollars what would be the best
thing to do with the money
so it earns interest and is worth more
once she's 18. wow
well i'm dave i'm so sorry to hear about
your loss my friend
um that's tough and i can't imagine uh
what you're going through i hope you've
got a good church and good friends
around you
but looking at this this dollar amount
this 858 survivor benefits coming in
this has got to become part of your
budget uh you're going to use this to
raise your daughter
yeah what whatever whatever baby step
you're on and
if you'll follow the stuff we teach by
the time she's 18 you'll you will have
fully funded her college fund and she'll
have a lot more than a hundred thousand
dollars
and you will have become wealthy
over that 20 years and she will have a
lot more than a hundred thousand dollars
and so there's not any moral ethical nor
legal
obligation for you to set this money
aside in her name
you spend more than 858 raising a kid a
month anyway
and so just put it into your budget and
work your budget because we're
counting on you to be a great dad and
anytime you work your budget it is for
the good
of you and your family yeah and so your
daughter is going to more than benefit
far beyond what the 858 dollars would
have done right by you doing the right
thing
people struggle with this child support
i should set it aside
no it's all part of the budget because
you spend more than those dollar figures
on kids anyway
yeah just to raise them yeah no without
a doubt
i mean the percentage of the the roof
replacement the percentage of the
electric bill the percentage of the
insurance
that the kid rides in the car the cost
of the car the value of the loss in the
car
uh the kid is receiving the benefit of
all of that and this is called raising
your children
in a family it's what it is and so
mathematically you spend
a lot more than that on the kids portion
of your life yeah and so there's no
you've done nothing wrong uh
by not setting it into a separate
account and as a matter of fact setting
it into a separate account i think would
be wrong
yeah it's the improper use of it it's
not the most efficient use of the money
so good question natalie is in canada hi
natalie
welcome to the ramsey show hi
dave thank you for taking my call
um i'm trying to figure out a few things
but the main thing is
whether or not to uh try and get my
husband on board with selling our house
i've brought it up a few times but he
really doesn't want to sell it at a loss
we moved uh a year ago about
an hour and a half away from his current
work he planned on getting job
job around where we live we live in the
middle of nowhere um
with the intention of being able to grow
our own food and just
be out in the country again where we
both kind of grew up
and um anyway it hasn't happened yet
he's trying but uh it hasn't happened
we just realized we were expecting
another so
we've got one toddler and another on the
way um
so he has a job it's just an hour away
an hour and a half yes so he's traveling
about three hours a day
but the income is uh he takes home about
uh
31 000 and some uh 30
almost uh 31 200 a month
and um we don't have any
um uh real issues i suppose with
spending that we're aware we don't
you know we don't have any money
subscriptions we don't have any money
no we don't have any money
thirty one thousand in the three hour
drive a day i know where your money
and babies i mean you're only any money
no
i i don't know how to convince them
we're we're both believers
um unfortunately because of covet all
the churches are shut down the one we
did get to know
it's closed now and we really haven't
developed any sense of community around
here
how much do you owe on the home natalie
okay uh so so far we have
we oh it's around
two hundred and eighty thousand okay uh
it was 300 just under 350 000 when we
lost how are you making a payment on
that making 31 grand
well we're losing we're leaving every
month how
um we
yeah i would guess how much is your
house one payment
one hundred and eighty three dollars
and how much do you all have in savings
right now
oh we're burning through it uh we've
probably got
yeah right now brought a thousand nine
hundred
left to our names in liquid
and you're burning how much no um
we are burning i don't just found two
got all kinds of papers in front of me
um two thousand seven hundred and seven
dollars
and forty so you don't even have a month
left
oh really no not really i mean two
thousand over nineteen hundred you don't
have any money left
yeah i don't know what to do i don't
know what to do
um i'm trying to okay i don't know let
me okay i'm a little bit confused let me
let me stop i i don't want to
i don't want to take your side and jump
all over him right now but that's how
i'm no no that's how i'm feeling i don't
like
well because this is absolutely asinine
that you guys have let this
that you've let this burn down to this
y'all should have been out there six
months ago
i agree and so i don't i don't
understand why we're in denial about
math
what's his problem he doesn't want to
show that a loss
i don't care he's going to lose it to
foreclosure
i know but you said you bought it at 350
correct
and it's now you owe 280. so what's it
what do you think it's worth now
i wish i knew we we haven't gotten the
price okay
so here's the steps i think in sitting
down and really sitting down with him
trying to hold his hands and i want you
to schedule i've scheduled a a
real estate agent to come over here
tomorrow night because tonight we're
about to have a come to jesus meeting
the math is over we cannot that we
cannot pretend anymore
you've got your head stuck up something
i don't know what it is and it's got to
come out yeah this is ridiculous
and put put his hand on your belly and
let him know you've got another baby
coming this is crazy
time time is on the edge i have i have
he's even finished your book we bought
your book on amazon
he read it he's so excited so gung-ho
he's not
going to look for more jobs now but it's
it's just not it's not about jobs it's
about this house is gone
yeah yeah yeah it's gotta be it's a
three-hour drive
with a pregnant wife who's scared and
he's out of money this house is gone
sell it before you lose it yeah what do
we do do we rent or
um you move to town and rent when we
went there
it was eighteen hundred a month you're
gonna have to get other jobs but listen
what your
your little dream of living in the
country and growing veggies has turned
into a nightmare yeah
yeah i know and so something's got to
change we can you cannot
stay where you are yeah it's not going
to work now then the only question is
where are we going
right and you got to start figuring that
out as a next step but this i i
i don't know what you were waiting on
were you waiting on the housing ferry to
show up
i mean it's not this isn't you know
unless you were going to have an income
all of a sudden start appearing that's
double yours it's not gonna work this is
not gonna work it's not
gonna go and so natalie the urgency you
hear in our voice
is that we don't want you all hanging
out for another two to three months
you don't have that you're never gonna
come get the house yeah you don't have
that time
so i would much rather you all make a
proactive decision reach out to your
lender have a real conversation
get the real estate agent the real
estate elp over tomorrow
you are moving yeah voluntarily
or otherwise you are moving
much rather you be in control
this is where you are and so let's face
it and decide what we're going to do
where are we moving because we're moving
yeah
this house is gone i'm so sorry i'm
sorry you guys have been through this
but you've i you got to deal with it you
cannot
you cannot not deal with it anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight
eight two five five two two five drew
is with us in chicago hi drew welcome to
the ramsey show how can we help
hi how are you great it's a pleasure to
speak with both of you too
um so uh my wife and i uh have been
davis for years
uh last march i was able to get my wife
a hundred percent on board uh i'm sure
the pandemic had a little bit to do with
that
um so uh we started using the every
dollar budget
uh which allowed us to pay off our uh
only vehicle loan
um got rid of all the credit cards that
we had
wonderful um cash flowed three kids uh
braces we've got a fully funded
emergency fund now
how does that feel oh it feels fantastic
good fantastic how's it feel to her
i'm sorry i said how does it feel to her
oh
uh she's she's wondering why we didn't
start it earlier
it was your fault say i told you so it
was your fault drew i'm sure i'm not i
don't know exactly how but i'm sure it
was your fault
drew do not say i told you so never
gonna work
right i wrote all right good good so
um so we have college coming up uh i
have uh
my three kids are 15 uh excuse me 17 15
and 14.
we have 27 000 left on the mortgage
um and uh based on uh
some advice you just gave jacob a little
while ago
i think part of my answer uh question
was answered um i
i do have a non-retirement brokerage
account
that i had 77 000 in
so i'm basically i was trying to figure
out what to do with that
should i pay off the 27 000 mortgage
should i open and fully fund
uh two roth retirement funds for my wife
and i
um what's your household income um
uh it's it's right at about 175.
excellent okay so here here's the here's
the uh
the hinge pin mathematically for your
whole situation
that'll set you guys free you need to
sit down and map out
for all three kids what you need what
they need for college
and how you're going to do that and when
you see that number and you see how
you're going to do it it's going to set
you free
to do the other stuff because here's
what's happening if i'm in your shoes
i'm you tell me if i'm wrong but i think
this is what how i would be feeling if i
was sitting there
i got this brokerage account i got a 27
000 mortgage i could easily pay it off
today
um and i need to get my iras funded but
god those kids that's coming at me like
a freight train right now
that that that big college bill is
looming and i don't know what it is
and i'm a little bit afraid if i pay
that mortgage off and i start my fifteen
percent baby step four into retirement
that i'm not gonna have the money for
college
right does that feel like and i do you
feel that way you have uh
i do i do i i now i i do have
uh a 457 uh through work
good um that that i have uh 150
about 150 000 all right so tell me the
ages of the kids again
uh 17 so uh she's a junior
um so we've got a little over a year and
a half um
15 he's a freshman and then uh 14.
so so i have that uh 457 also
and they my employer
just changed the management of that 457
and as for the past many years
they didn't offer a roth uh option and
now they do
so i've stopped putting into the regular
i've opened up the roth but it's
you know so i still have the okay here's
what i'm gonna do if i'm in your shoes
all right i'm just going to throw some
numbers down just for the fun of it but
i want you to go do a formal version of
this with your wife
okay let's let's say we research the
kids college
and a hundred thousand dollars will put
them through
each i don't think it will quite but i'm
going to use that number for a minute
okay so over the next four years
because i've got a 14 year old i need
300 grand
that makes sense yes i make 175
and so if i did four into 300 that'd be
75 a year
i can cash flow that
right yes you see how having the numbers
helps you relax a little bit
so i know 75 000 a year for four years
and or a hundred thousand dollars a year
yeah for four years
you can cash flow that now a hundred
percent of the time i'm going to write a
check tonight
and pay off your mortgage knowing that i
can get there because you've already got
50 of your 300 to 400 that you're going
to need
77 minus 27 is 50 right yup right
okay i got 50 of it now the only
question is in order to cash flow it am
i going to have to tap the brakes a
little bit on my retirement in order to
cash flow college because i got college
right here on top of me
of course the kids are going to go to
school they're going to they're going to
take uh
act testing and they're going to take it
again they're going to apply for
scholarships we're going to affordable
schools we're not going to uber
expensive schools you don't have the
money
and you're going to go to you know
something you can afford but
even having done all of that you're
looking at a three to four hundred
thousand dollar bill
over this period of time yeah roughly
andrew once you do this
you've got your mortgage payment now
freed up because you paid off your house
yeah so the only question that remains
is
how much retirement am i going to be
able to do while i'm cash flowing
college for the next
four years actually it's right so
there's one
uh wrinkle there too i i also will be
receiving a pension
um of probably right at about a hundred
thousand
when you retire or a lump sum no when i
retire
oh but we're not retiring anything way
down the road
yeah because when the kids are through
school you're gonna load retirement
when the kids are when the kids are
through school you're gonna load up
retirement yeah because
you you've got that money so you can do
this you're going to be good buddy
now what you have to do is stay allergic
to stupid from now on you got to map it
out and you got to map out the kids
school
yeah and and have some firm discussions
starting tonight
on where you're going to school where
you're not 17 year old yeah i mean and
this is
this is real but i'm writing a check
paying off the house i got 50
started towards my three to four hundred
thousand dollar need
over the next four years before the last
one starts school
but we really have a total of eight
years to spread it across
so this makes it even more doable so you
can map out the actual cash needs
so the 17 year old starts i need this
much cash this year right so you got
your one out of your 50.
you probably got year two out of your
50. now the 15 year old starts school
and you got three and four for the first
one and you got the second one
right and you're going to end up with uh
two in school for quite a few years
at the same time but you can map that
cash out
and and out of your cash flow in your
budget again
with a reasonably priced education and
you're going to be able to do that and
then back into how much can i put
towards retirement
out of that and paying cash for school
so i'm going to have the discussion with
them about that
and we got but if once you map this out
it's going to give you a ton of peace
just like when you start doing a budget
you feel like you got a raise but all
we're doing is we're mapping out the
next eight years which gets the 14 year
old four years starting school four
years to finish school yeah and now
you're not guessing you're not you don't
have this thing looming over your head
where you're wondering
you can sit down and actually know and
once you put a dollar amount to it now
you can put a savings plan toward it
yeah this will work this will absolutely
work hold on i'm gonna have kelly send
you a copy of debt free degree
number one bestseller by anthony o'neil
and you guys need to read that and the
kids need to read it
uh is it'll help you understand that you
can get a degree
debt-free especially when mom and dad
are 100
debt free house and everything and make
175 k
ding ding it's doable it's very doable
but we got to plan it out we got to
think about it and you can't you're not
going to
no one accidentally wins the super bowl
it doesn't happen
we noticed that the other night
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day ecclesiastes 7
12 for the protection
of wisdom is like the protection of
money and the advantage of knowledge
is that wisdom preserves the life of him
who has it john zinger says
great leaders are not defined by the
absence of weakness but rather by the
presence of clear
strengths i've heard that one that is a
good that's a good one that is a good
one
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host here today
david is with us in houston texas hi
david how are you
you know i don't know whether to say
better than i deserve or focus but not
finished
i'm doing pretty well that's a pretty
good hogan impersonation there that
david i'm gonna give you an a on that
one
okay thanks hey um i've got a question
for y'all
uh i'm 30 years old married i have
two kids three and under with one on the
way and
i am blessed to be debt free except for
a mortgage
um we got about 125k left to pay off on
that
um kind of a backstory is you know i
grew up kind of as an fbu kid my parents
did it back in
i read your book dave total money
makeover in 2008
and we did fp as a couple in 2013.
but i'm kind of struggling now um with
baby steps and burnout now we're on baby
steps four five and six
we purchased our home in 2015 as double
income no kids
and then in 2017 uh my wife quit after
we had our daughter in the middle of
hurricane harvey
and took a big pay cut there to about
70k
then i was blessed out of promotion
before i i got a 42
pay raise in 2019 so now i'm making
about 110k
um so my question i guess is you know
with all the things that i've found
the more money i make the more things
you have to pay for whether that's 529
for the kids
home insurance life insurance property
tax
etc so how can i keep
my eyes and our eyes on our financial
goal without running out of gas
during dates that's four five and six
well the first thing that comes to mind
is
baby steps one through three are gazelle
intensity
and four five and six are not you move
from intensity
intensity to intentionality
on for on four five and six so four five
and six
involves a budget for a vacation
it involves a budget for an upgraded
vehicle it involves a budget for
you're running a marathon here you're
not running a sprint
and so you're not on beans and rise rice
and beans and you make 110 000 you've
done very well in your career
well done you're putting 15 percent of
your income away you don't have any
payments but a house payment you've got
an emergency fund in place
you have a very reasonable house
mortgage and you got some kids and
you're funding a 529
but you're you're slowing into a rhythm
run now you're not doing speed training
it's a marathon and i think you're still
have the trying to run the emotions at
least
if not maybe even trying to crank the
math down
as if you were still on gazelle
intensity that'll burn you up
you can't do that yeah and david you're
also at that stage of life
where you've got all of these young kids
you got another one coming
so you're feeling the pressure and
destroying you're gonna get out
yeah along with them along with lack of
sleep are you working from home too
yes sir oh yeah man so you let's let's
be honest
the mindset on the financial side is
they've said it's a mindset it's the
intentionality factor
but what you're feeling is the stress
and strain from the other things of life
and i want to tell you as a former
master isolator
because i was perfect at it i thought
you don't want to do life alone
and so you want to get some good guys
around you you want to have a connection
and a relationship to talk about
the stressors and strains of the kids of
the pressure
uh it's one of those things where we're
not meant to do life alone so you need
some community
yeah and
you know it's the stage you're in oh yes
i mean you've got
uh there's not a lot of traction
mathematically
with where you are in these baby steps
and
the kids just keep piling up here and
you're
just like i'm stuck and he doesn't get
to leave
he's working from home yeah yeah there's
a lot that's a lot
you know you you're i think just saying
all that out loud
oh helps with the idea of burnout that
yes
a normal human being in your situation
would be stressed yes
so if you are stressed you are a normal
human you are normal you are not a
psychopath
no and if you were just clueless then i
would tell you i'd worry about your
mental health
you are feeling exactly where you are
right now in this season brother
we'll get you out of the house and
working yeah that'll be helpful it will
and we get the baby here the last one
that'll be that'll be gonna be the
the that'll be helpful yeah and you get
in there you know but you're not going
to see
one of the frustrations that we've
watched people experience and i guess
we've all experienced that walk these
baby steps
is that you see such huge chunks of
traction
in the first three yeah and then when
you go to four five and six it just
slows down yes
and it's the long haul this is a it's a
five
seven year ten year slog that's just a
thought and we're just
that's why we budget in there for the
upgrades and some of the other things as
you go along you budget
right for this or that and um you know
if you need to back off on a 529 just a
little bit
in order to breathe have a fun
fund yes a little bit while you're here
this is the time that it's appropriate
to do that i just want you doing it on
purpose
and i don't want you to fall into debt
right because you take your
take your eyes completely off the ball
so you go from intensity to
intentional yeah and that's where we
want to be and david just like the
seasons of the weather this season too
will change my friend
it really will just hang in there with
your wife make sure you guys
relationship is connected
get some coaching if you need to or some
counseling if you need to
but get some good guys around you so you
can do life with them
because you got other fellows that are
feeling the same thing you know it's
weird it feels like it's yesterday in
some ways and in some ways it feels like
it was a hundred years ago but
the year rachel was born we filed
bankruptcy
we had no money that's why you filed
bankruptcy
and i got a toddler a marriage hanging
on by a thread
i'm working from home and i'm broke
i got no money and um
you know sharon was to say the least
overwhelmed she
wanted me away she didn't want to look
at me to start with right then
that's pretty disgusted uh valid valid
but uh you know i mean we went through a
similar season
uh but much worse yeah in the sense of
there was not money for
uh the electric bill and there was not
money you know we're
i mean we didn't go hungry literally but
we were broke
we had no money and i had to go make
money every week in order to just pull
things together
and i got little babies my self-esteem
is destroyed
my marriage is on the rocks i mean it's
that was a tough tough season
and so it feels like when i talk about
it it comes up in my throat
and i remember it like it was yesterday
but it was you know 30 years ago
so uh in that sense david you're in a
similar type thing but much better
and i'm not saying yours is that your
your feelings aren't valid they are
valid
right uh but you're just that that's
what
that those young that young kid stage of
life they suck they suck the
marrow out of your bones yes emotionally
that's what they they're so needy takers
um we love them they're cute as they can
be but that's why
when i have all the grandbabies over i
mean that's how i send them back home
that's why i send them back home because
i love them but they need to go home
have to go home you know and it's just
they you know
when you're when you're six months old
and you can't do anything for yourself
you're
all you are is a taker man i mean we
love you you're cute as a button
and uh papa dave's gonna bounce you on
my knee but um
but they they do they pull the energy
out of
and the math out of everything and and
so it is valid to feel that
it's not really a burnout it's more of a
i'm not getting traction yeah fatigue
it's a fatigue
it is a fatigue yeah it's a mental it's
a math fatigue an emotional fatigue a
spiritual fatigue
it is a relational fatigue yep and uh so
yeah just own that and and say that
that's real get some guys
guys of young families around you like
chris suggested yeah
form your group of guys get out of the
house yes
go to the store and just walk around go
in the backyard and hit a tree with a
stick
i don't know do something man i mean uh
that's get out of that house yeah let
your wife get out of the house too
take turns take turns yeah for god's
sakes yeah budget for a babysitter
that's a good thing
yeah i mean i'm with you brother that's
what we're saying but you'll get through
it and you can still hit your baby step
yes you can just don't let this cause
you to fall off the horse
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
you